retired animal James Winnefeld is with
us now he was vice chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff during the Obama
administration Admiral good morning good
morning Gail listen good morning to you
even before Donald Trump became a
presidential candidate he was very vocal
in his criticism of the Obama
administration's handling of Afghanistan
he certainly turned it up a few notches
when he became a candidate but last
night he said for the first time when
you sit at the desk in the Oval Office
you were forced to make different and
difficult decisions what did you make of
what appears to be a big change of heart
for him well Gail this was about the
transition from shrill and simple
rhetoric on a campaign trail and to sort
of adult grown-up decisions on very very
complicated national security problems
and I give the president a little bit of
credit for actually listening to his
national security advisors not just the
military but the full spectrum of
advisers and he actually changed his
mind it was almost a stunning admission
if he is very difficult to hear that
he's changed his mind it has but it gave
me the sense that there are some areas
where he realizes that he's probably
outflanked in expertise and he really
needs to listen to these people right I
do think that he asked the right
questions which is a president's
responsibility to do what are our
security interests there versus what are
the prices that we're going to have to
pay in order to protect those interests
and at the end of the day you listen to
his advisers and I think he came up with
a reasonable way forward step in the
right direction you think I think it's a
it's a reasonable way forward minor
changes to existing policy to be quite
honest with you but again a sort of a
sustainable counterterrorism approach in
Afghanistan Admiral the cliche question
is what is an additional 4,000 do that
140,000 boots on the ground did not
would you advocate a full withdrawal at
this point no I would not advocate a
full withdrawal think the president was
clear in sort of the n's ways means
balance of strategy that our ends remain
intact there and that is to prevent
future attacks on this country and on
this city from a place like Afghanistan
he made it very clear that those threats
still exist what he did was sort of
fine-tune the approach on the face of it
percentage-wise it's a 50% increase it's
really only four thousand troops which
is a fairly modest increase those troops
will do more to train advise and assist
the Afghan national security forces to
enable them to
handle this problem themselves do you
think that this is really a Korea like
situation as General Petraeus has said
which is US troops are just gonna have
to be there for the long haul well you
know and one of the characteristics of
21st century war seems to me that there
really is no crisply defined and state
which we as Americans love to have if if
you ask you know sort of what is what is
victory mean in Afghanistan you'd like
for it to mean a nice stable Afghan
government that it's not threatened by
the Taliban or terrorists but in fact
it's probably the end state would be
that there are no attacks conducted on
this country from that nation a
commander in Afghanistan once told me
you go to a high school in America and
you ask how many of you are willing to
die for your country and every hand goes
up and then he says how many are willing
to die for your County and they look
around confused in Afghanistan it's the
opposite you've got tribes who will
fight for a valley or a village but the
idea of a cohesive country is completely
foreign to them how does nation-building
I guess that's what happened to
nation-building as a mission correct
well when I think you know the president
was a little bit all over the place last
night on this he talked about you know
we aren't going to do nation building in
Afghanistan anymore and then turned
right around and talked about using all
elements of national power helping them
with the economy and having an end state
where the Afghans can take care of this
problem themselves that sounds a lot
like nation-building but he also made it
clear that we're there to take out the
terrorist threat to defend this country
what are the pressure points on Pakistan
because the Obama administration really
struggled with this - you know of all of
our many allies and partners around the
world
Pakistan candidly is one of the most
difficult in that sort of South Asian
culture they will undermine you at the
same time they support you
we both have interests at stake in that
region and sometimes Pakistani interests
are different from ours and sometimes
they coincide there is no black or white
you know you're either with us or
against us with Pakistan you have to
deal with it as it is and I think it's
going to take a lot of diplomatic
pressure we didn't mention a lot about
diplomacy laughs yeah I think the the
real room for diplomacy is to make is to
make sure that our NATO partners are on
board which it sounds like they are
based on what we're hearing from Jens
Stoltenberg their secretary-general this
morning
and also intense pressure on Pakistan to
step up a little bit more than they have
been well we'll keep we'll keep
reporting on it Admiral thank you for
your analysis you're very welcome